hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we are back with the
glory that is jujutsu kaisen
a series that is pretty seriously
stepped up during the so-dark the cursed
training arc which is utter insanity
because trainiacs are usually well
they're usually pretty junk
this one though worked pretty damn
brilliantly it's very similar to the
idea of you subscribing to the new world
review in order to receive regular
injections of jujutsu kaizen content
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
remember because this is a blind review
i sadly can't read your comments due to
fear of spoilers
but i can observe your numbers so if you
are enjoying this then please do the
like thing and the subscribe thing for
more but the premise of this arc is
quite simple
yuji itadori is dead but then he isn't
and instead of being dead yuji watches
movies meanwhile gojo proceeds to become
the main protagonist
of jujutsu kaisen i really don't think
that's at all an inaccurate summation
and i am all here for it the biggest
problem with the previous arc was very
simple
not enough gojo and that was very much
rectified here as we received more
insight into this man and his abilities
and i honestly thought we would at this
early stage and first up we're beginning
to learn more and more about his true
goals in this world which can be summed
up as something of a revolution i
suppose but the very interesting part to
me is gojo's clarity on this matter
because whenever the concept of a
revolution is brought up probably the
most immediate thought is revolution by
force you know the public holding power
to account through some sort of
organized action whether that be violent
like overthrowing a monarchy or
disruptive like going on a strike but
this arc has given me the impression
that gojo is practically an unstoppable
force
and if he really wanted to he could
probably institute a jujutsu revolution
on this world fairly easily but that
would not result in permanent change
instead gojo prefers the philosophy of
generational revolution
much much much slower but also much much
much more powerful so he focuses very
much on fostering yuji and the other
students to one day inherit the world
with his ideals in mind which is
interesting because it's a direct
counterpoint to the other cursed spirit
dude whose name is jogo
which you know in japanese is just gojo
backwards but his idea is the more
traditionally
violent revolution in order to install a
power structure of what i believe he
called
new humans which is a fascinating term
because for lack of a better and
or more creative word it humanizes these
cursed spirits through jogo's eyes or i
singular they are just an evolution of
humanity it blurs these once distinct
lines of evil
curse dudes and i hope that jujutsu
kaisen continues to do so as well and
with that said yuji is of course the
perfect vessel for that kind of
discussion because he is currently the
amalgamation of a human and a cursed
spirit so the inner conflict within yuji
may just be a simplistic incarnation of
global conflict at large
that or i am just reading far too much
into things which
can happen but even if that was the case
i like that jujutakaisen is engaging me
in this way now speaking of engaging by
far the best part of this arc for me was
the rapid expansion of curse mechanics
another thing that didn't really quite
hit with me in the previous arc was
being thrust into this curse-based
scenario and not really having any idea
how things function outside of this kind
of simplistic grading system so the
whole dump truck of concepts and
information was absurdly valuable to me
during the sock and i now see why people
kept insisting that jujutsu kaisen was
similar to hunter hunter in terms of the
power system aspect on a very basic
level it does appear at this stage
anyway to function quite similarly to
nen which i want to emphasize
is not a bad thing not a bad thing at
all i still think that nen is the
greatest power system ever invented in
pretty much all of media so curses being
similar to nen can only infinitely
benefit
jutsukai sen in my opinion but if i
understand this correctly
and to be fair i may not but one can
manifest cursed energy as a direct
response to emotion
specifically negative emotion and with
that energy you can then construct a
curse technique
so yeah quite similar to using aura to
forge your fuel none abilities but i am
intrigued by the idea that this energy
can only be spawned through negative
emotions not
positive ones i love that thought so
much because it's just so damn twisted
like i don't know this might be wrong
but right now to me what this signifies
is that the stronger of a jujuta
sorcerer you are the more you need to
inhabit that place of pure pain
let's take gojo for example dude is an
insanely powerful sorcerer so just how
negative do his emotions need to be in
order to produce that energy like what
kind of hell has this man been through
to land at this place of power and i
guess that makes sense because it really
isn't a casual content thought
you don't want to instigate a fun little
revolution that and his raw hatred of
those currently in charge being on full
display make me wonder just how dark
this man truly is behind his comical
facade and i suppose that's also how
yuji could really break the mould in
jiu-jitsu kaisen
being this insanely positive personality
that draws more from sukuna's power than
the negative emotions of his own i
know it's just a fun stuff to think
about as is another vaguely explored
mechanic being the binding vow it was
very exciting to see that whole section
happen because of course it immediately
gave me flashbacks of setting nen vows
and n restrictions which almost always
results in the most fascinating of hunt
hunter abilities so i'm very keen to
explore these vowels and i'm also very
glad to know that yes crazy power can be
achieved but it will come at a cost
whether that be through a vowel or just
needing to fuel mental negativity to
achieve more and more energy this whole
system seems incredibly high risk
high reward and of course i should
mention the particularly unique feature
introduced to us during the sock being
domain expansion i really enjoy this
because we've got to see what like four
domains this arc gojos jogos sukunas and
the mysterious antagonist character with
like the other messed up face
but i like these because domains appear
to be not just a cool way to fight but
also a direct manifestation of character
take gojo for example once again because
he is the best example of anything but
his domain was essentially
infinite of all of the things however
when faced with the ability to access
absolutely everything you become unable
to do anything which i don't know is the
idea that without limitations and any
form of decision making just becomes
impossible like a more extreme version
of going out to dinner with a friend and
being unable to choose a restaurant
because there's just like a billion
around you and neither of you are
decisive but this also seems to be very
representative of what i know of gojo
himself in reality he seems like this
man with limitless power but he also
can't use it due to his personal
philosophy of change i mean just imagine
that being the undisputed most powerful
force in the world and having all of
that power being utterly meaningless
when it comes to enacting the thing it
is you want to do meanwhile there are
much more simplistic domains as well
like jogos which was just
i'm in angry cyclops dude so my domain
is fiery and violent there they're there
but the idea of domain versus domain
combat is just this epic amped up battle
of i suppose two personalities
it's cool and it will make me pay a lot
of attention to environmental and
conceptual detail when it comes to these
particular spaces
also from a more meta perspective
domains are pretty brilliant because it
allows akutami to consistently create
new and fun environments for our eyes to
feast upon because lack of environmental
intrigue is always a bit of a worry when
your series is set in modern day tokyo
locations risk becoming a bit boring
because other than concrete buildings
and maybe if you're lucky
some some like trees if we go far enough
out into the country you don't really
tend to have much to work with and
what's worse is that your series can
start to look like
literally every other shonen manga also
set
in modern day tokyo because there's a
lot of them but domains pretty much
solve that potential aesthetic hole so
i'm very much loving and looking forward
to seeing more of them and all of this
information that i've gone through is a
huge part of why this particular
training arc works
those two words training and arc they
get a pretty terrible rap in the shona
manga fan base and to be fair
training arcs are often bland inspired
and usually the unfortunate result of an
author digging themselves into a deep
deep hole like creating an antagonist
far too powerful and not being able to
think of a creative way for the
protagonist to overcome them so you need
to resort to
uh training and encountering this kind
of arc a couple of hundred chapters into
the series is a
very bad sign for the health of said
series however where training arcs work
best are right here in the beginning
jiu-jitsu kaisen takes full advantage of
a training act to thoroughly explain and
develop a power system as well as begin
developing yuji
straight from level zero at this point
the readers are still new to the
characters the world
and the power system so we almost crave
some sort of training arc to develop
these things further but where it can
really hurt as if we need a training arc
for a character to go from like level
100 to 150 at that point fatigue sets in
and it can seem like a bit of a grind so
i think that jujutsu kaisen has handled
this pretty perfectly thus far with some
great action as well with
gojo versus jo go and actually that's a
pretty big thing i should bring up we
see gojo's eyes oh my god they are
surprisingly
stunningly beautiful not at all what i
was expecting and i'd be keen to know
why he wears the blindfold in everyday
life my initial thinking is that this
would be a binding vowel or whatever
setting a restriction that he can't use
his eyes outside of his domain in
exchange for making his domain more
powerful or for it to be capable of
existing in the first place
and speaking of fights yes i've mostly
glossed over it until now but yuji
vsukuna was quite something as well
in the uh the corpsey inner domain it
was interesting because it was quite
clear that tsukuna was always in control
but what
really hit me was round two when yuji
fought for the right to be brought back
to life with no restrictions and then
tsukino just sliced his head in two
whilst yuji was still speaking which i
imagine is a mere glimpse of sukuna's
true power and what was happening
previously was more akin to an adult
humoring a child
because part of me did think that yeah
eugene might actually be doing well in
this place because he is a crazy
superhuman after all but no all yuji hit
was the infinity between them and i
guess that brings us back to gojo
because i really love that infinity
concept the idea that the closer you get
to him the more you slow down and thus
it makes it impossible to ever really
you know hit him it very much reminds me
of a stand in part six of jojo's bizarre
adventure called green green grass of
home which had a very similar idea
except the closer you get to it the more
you shrunk and thus you would never be
able to reach it because the distance
always remains the same and i bring that
up because it really is one of the more
insane jojo's stand so seeing power like
this demonstrated institute's kaisen
is no joke this man has a terrifying set
of abilities at his direct disposal
meanwhile the end of the arc also
introduces us to some rival students one
of which likes girls with
big butts which fair enough and the
other of which like shooting people
shooting people with gun i have to say i
have no strong opinion on either of them
thus far but i do like what they
represented which was to thoroughly
decimate fushiguru and kugasaki because
whilst not entirely conclusive the two
of them hit a nice wall with these brief
opponents and hitting walls is always
necessary before discovering how to
break through them and become
better at the thing the thing in this
case being jiu-jitsu sorcery although i
will say that kugi-saki is
unfortunately still pretty much just a
nothing character to me with reacts in
and i still have
legitimately no idea why she exists
which is kind of important for her
status as you know a
main character but all she really did in
this arc was purchase a tracksuit get
annoyed at vending machines and get
shots
like a bunch of times and that sums up
her entire training act so i'd really
like a reason to uh to care about her in
any
way at some point i'm sure it's coming
but right now i'm actually even more
interested in maki because we did
discover that she cannot use cursed
energy so she has the whole struggle
against the system going on which is
very endearing and i like her a lot more
as a result of that information
also fusiguro continues to grow on me i
really like the scene where he visited
the random dude's mother and apologized
for not being able to save him which is
nice because despite the fact that
fushiguro wasn't so keen on saving the
guy himself he did have this clear
desire to help the mother whom he deems
as a good person
oh and of course panda continues to be
panda which is always appreciated
don't ever change but that pretty much
does it for this blind review of
jiu-jitsu kaisen's curse training arc
and what do you guys think please do
leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some multitude
sorcery then please do check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for very maybe regular jujutsu
kaisen morbidity delivered straight into
your youtube feed but for now this has
been the new world review and i'll see
you next time